[Music]
[Music]
well here we are dominic mahonigan it's
malhogeningen is it yeah dude i told you
that i'm trying i'm thinking of taking
the g out i don't know about that i like
it monahan yeah but i was working with
someone the other day who i know and
they mentioned my name and they were
like blah blah blah dominic mcnuggen
well let's not start on the donut tom
how are you tell me something happy
that's happened to you this week
something wonderfully wonderful i've
been enjoying playing this very
difficult new game
elden
i've heard the banner it's very similar
to
lord of the rings which i'm
unfortunately uh
should stop banging on about as much but
the the preamble to
the uh game much like kate blanchett's
uh wonderful voiceover in the film it's
kind of like
the lands have been ruined and a ring
was created but then it went missing and
it's created imbalance in the world and
you must find the ring i'm assuming
right but billy i tell you what because
i i played skyrim back in the day i've
not played it for a while because it's
quite dated but the thing with skyrim is
you know
you can get away with missing a couple
of spells to try and down a bad
baddie
and if they take a couple of swipes at
you with a club and it hits you yeah you
know you'll be all right because it's a
it's a game it's not it's not real and
stuff like that or maybe you dodge or
maybe you slip off a cliff and you're
right in this
it's kind of like
art imitates life if you get hit
and you're not guarding yourself by a
sword you'll die if you slip whilst
running away and someone throws
a fiery spell at you and it hits your
feet then your feet are on fire and you
know you're probably not gonna be able
to use your feet anymore and then you'll
get killed so it's quite unforgiving
not to be confused with the clinton
eastwood film unforgiven which was
brilliant
but
see when you when you are killed you
need to go right back to the start you
don't go back to the start but you do
lose all your runes which is the way
that you level up and the way that you
get better at the game but
let's say you get killed by a monster
scary monster the map one time will show
you where your runes are right so you'll
wake up again and on your map there'll
be a little sign to say if you want to
go back and pick up all those runes that
you just lost and it might be
you can go but if you get killed on the
way done
how many hours have you played i think
i've probably played something like 10
hours how many times would you reckon
you'd die in an hour
in an
hour somewhere between six and eight
seven
yeah
yeah
but hey talking of games what we played
a couple of majestic games on the rift
didn't we i love how madinah i love love
love heimerdinger let's do it very quick
fling up legends
we usually play with our friend nigel
he's away on a trip we saw him recently
so he's not troubled with his computer
and i hate you up there today and said
do you want to play a league and you
said yeah and you're so good at
heimerdinger now you're playing wherever
you want i'll put him anywhere in fact
you wrote to me and said you want to
play some rift when i was on the toilet
i said give me a minute john i just need
to finish up here yeah yeah you don't
want to end that halfway through
and then off we went i've got a slow
computer just now so it took me ages to
log in and then with a couple of great
games didn't we i'm glad i'm up top i
don't like playing high mid i like them
in the middle
and i don't mind them as adc as well if
you know the support yeah if you don't
support but it's interesting because it
was only probably two or three weeks ago
that you said to the gang that we play
with i just can't get my head around top
i don't like it yeah it's a long lane
it's an unforgiving lane if you play it
and you get yourself found out it's a
long way back to your turret and you
said i don't think i'll really ever play
top
you're like a top master now i like it
and who were you playing that was a new
character i played
zerath in mid
did all right still learning him he's
okay he's very long range and he's fun
and then after that
you played heimerdinger again and i
played jinx and we were victorious when
the enemy team were running down mid
lane yeah and get you guys yeah i
managed to kind of almost break in
sneaky behind the back of their base and
kill their base when they weren't even
watching just yourself that was good i
loved it hey should we answer a couple
of questions come on because we it's the
second part of our fantastic interview
with casper today yeah casper's great eh
what a fantastic story yeah but we
should answer a couple of questions do
you want to hear about fatima and spain
i do right we hear this fatima is a
teacher of english in her home country
and she recommends our podcast to our
students because they may improve their
english level
some of the students are fans of lauder
ring saga and they're curious to know
the answer to this question
why do you think
mary and pippen preferred to stay in
middle-earth instead of traveling to the
undying lands just the same as sam and
gimli did in their old age because we
would have been invited wouldn't we i
think i know the answer to this
go on
i don't think we're allowed to go at the
undying lands well how come sam did
because you can only go
if you were the ring bearer if you held
onto the ring and he did for a moment
earlier so because of that sam is
allowed to go to the undying lands what
about kimberly
i don't did gimli go well that's what
that's what famine said farmers saying
that but i don't know if you if you know
the answer to this in fact fatima if you
uh or your students
know the answer to that we'd love to um
confirm to our listeners that gimli did
go and also if that's true that only
ring bearers are allowed to go to the
undyne land um or elves of course or
else of course or wizards of wizards but
not dwarfs i wouldn't think so was gimli
ever the ring bearer
if anyone can help us well the other
thing is that you and i had a few things
that we needed to take care of we became
kind of
in some way
uh heads of
you know responsible
that's terrible english they're dumb no
it's all right i'm gonna back up a
little bit and fat and my students like
to use this podcast that's about english
a bad example we became kind of
responsible members of the shire didn't
we yeah you you were very
well that became the the thin thing what
did you become it's just mary the
magnificent the white mack neverson i
don't know just he was amazing in war
battles in the scaring of the shire and
then you know maybe it was just what how
he dressed yeah and then later on in our
older age we took a little minor tour
around middle earth didn't we went to
gondor we went to rohan
we saw aragorn
and then we get buried with them which
we're hoping to do with viggo aren't we
but he doesn't seem keen yeah does he
say he's not spoken about that for a
while actually that's all right we've
got a message here
on our youtube page french bunion from
rutgers plague what an amazing name
that's good
who said if you guys could have been in
any 80s fantasy movie example legend
willow labyrinth cruel and so on
which would you pick
a
fantasy film could as would uh could i
pick the princess braid that's a fantasy
film that's a fantasy film isn't it and
i love sword fencing that's good great
fencing in it
i would say
bob the sword bob the sword anderson
absolutely that's 100 points for you
thank you yeah princess bride for you oh
i mean i'm a
they don't have any human characters in
the dark crystal but i really love the
dark crystals as a kid sometimes you
don't look quite human
here what do i look like i don't know
like something from the black crystal
the black crystal the new one
slightly darker than the dark crystal
interestingly enough yeah i'd go dark
crystal
and uh you'd go princess bride brilliant
some real laugh out loud moments in the
princess bride day
yeah
and andre the giant be good to have
worked with him wouldn't it i've i've
met carrie always a few times and he's a
lovely chat lovely guy i've met him i
think once i'll tell you a film that he
likes that you're in what the lord of
the rings what the trilogy yeah because
he i think he and uh sean aston have
been friends for a while but he's a big
fan great stuff talking to big fans
we've got our second part yeah of our uh
fantastic interview with
casper and as we said last week there
were a few minor little technical
details that went wrong
with my particular broadcast because i
was in yosemite you were here with
casper
unfortunately
some of the audio and video from my side
of things isn't great but the interview
with casper
is so fantastic and the music that you
guys did is so fantastic that we hope
you guys will forgive us for that yeah
we worked out the best that we could
it's not our fault it's the internet's
fault yeah yeah blame the internet yeah
i won't yeah correct so here's the
second part of our conversation with
casper rife
we have a listener dom i came in and we
had a few gifts i thought i don't want
to open them all when dom's not here
because he gets angry and he does beat
me yeah casper okay yeah and i knew that
actually but i did open one and it's got
a very nice letter in it dom but this
person has also put in a riddle
that i think they have written themself
and it's um it's a lord of the rings
riddle now uh the person is called maybe
casper can help us out well we can only
hope
no i'll do my best it's from a
alex winters
from olympia in
a what w a what state would w a be what
one
what
washington
washington
so that would be washington state
now dom you're not here so i will have
to pass this on to uh casper
if this was a map of the united states
of america
that would be florida
new york
california
was it that what yes california
florida new york where is washington
state
once more that where's california
california over there okay texas well so
florida see okay but but that's new york
no it's is that the opposite way yeah
it's turned the opposite way okay so
california new york
no that's got to be the side with new
york because it's my thumb
so that's going to be new york up there
you can have it either way you want okay
and and which one do you want me to find
i want you to find let me see now hold
on
yes that way so i want you to find
washington state
not washington
um
the other one yeah it's it's north right
it's it's pretty pretty far north yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah up there up here
yeah yeah as north as that
yeah yeah
johnny clues
pretty pretty no no two thirds of a
finger off that's not bad or somebody
from denmark
well done
well anyway alex winters from olympia
and washington state says she loves the
podcast especially the stories dom can
you tell us a story you haven't sold
before that's a hard that's a hard
question that tom billy
uh
what was it like working on doom patrol
we've already covered that today so that
was good
i wrote you guys a lot of the rings
riddle
i hope you like it dom i thought of you
when i saw these tackies she sent some
new tacky stuff they're blue blue heat
they're called have you tried them i'm
not trying to do i'm all about the fuego
i'll try the blue no question uh if you
want to try something funky check out my
type by since mozelle keep being your
lovely selves what lovely things they
say alex that's lovely anyway here is
the riddle everybody get ready
um it's quite a difficult one if we
could john could we put this on the
screen
beyond the chasms deep
before the trees so sweet
among the eleanor and nifridel
cresting high upon this hill
eight
there are here eight there are here yet
nine there where and though his heart
may yearn never again shall aragon
return
it used to be nine and now there's only
a so it's after boromir has been killed
right
it's among the eleanor and
i think i think it said galatrials in
lothalorian because they only ate there
as well gandalf dropped down
in in casa dome right of course there's
only and i think it's and and ganda or
aragon will never return to la florian
after did they ever return to imon hen
not to my knowledge i'm going to say it
same on hen
where boromir
didn't do too well but what is eleanor
and nephrodil maybe that's plants that
only grow in one place
i i think i think it sounds
yes it's it's it's um it's in lothlorien
as far as i recall i may be wrong dom
i'll go i'll go with you guys because to
be honest i don't really
know
so it's either
casper says lost lorien or i say amon
hen
i'll probably lean towards casper's eye
yeah just like that you know he seems
just nervous
it is
oh we're right about the oven thing okay
uh ke is it karen or seren am roth
kerr amroth yeah karen ambrose or the
mound of king amroth the heart of
elvendom
on middle earth
how would we know that it must have been
because of those plants i think yeah we
yeah we've we blew it no we did all
right i think we did all right we got
the elvis thing well thanks very much
alex that was a very good one and uh
well done for writing your own um thanks
alex your own uh
riddle that's a fantastic thing
no one has a business like yours with
all its strengths and challenges to
succeed you need a hiring partner that
adapts to your needs and that is
indeed
if you're hiring you need indeed because
indeed is the hiring partner where you
get to attract
interview and hire all in one place
and indeed is the only job site where
you're guaranteed to find quality
applications that meet your must-have
requirements or else you don't pay
instead of spending hours on multiple
job sites
hoping to find candidates with the right
skills you need just one powerful hiring
partner that can help do it all
for you
start hiring right now with
75 dollar sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
offer valid through april 30th
go to indeed.com
onion to claim your 75 dollar credit
before april 30th
indeed dot com
slash onion
terms and conditions apply
need to hire
you need indeed
now we're all trying to eat healthy
we're trying to do the right thing stay
fit
but i tell you what it's hard to eat
healthy for me in the morning breakfast
very difficult i tell you who makes it
easy
magic spoon
fantastic flavors i love it it's great
cereal but without all the horrible
stuff
we're all trying to cut down in carbs
sugar unhealthy foods you realize
there's not much i can eat now well
magic spoon is absolutely delicious and
i'll tell you some facts
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in every serving
there's only 140 calories and a serving
is keto friendly gluten free grain free
soy free and it's low carb
build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are
cocoa delicious fruity
frosted peanut butter cookies and cream
maple waffle blueberry cinnamon plus the
newly
reformulated
honey nut flavor now i love that one
i've been eating that this week
it's now in the permanent collection
so go to magicspoon.com
onion to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code onion
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
it's around this time of the day casper
when me and dom normally have a snack
okay
dom can't have a snack because he's not
here so i'll have double snack okay
dom
it's okay
because this is my favorite part of the
show i'll tell you how kind casper is he
he baked a cake
yeah
and he stuck some in a freezer so you
can have it next week
billy and dom eat the
world this is a traditional danish cake
is that right
tell us all about it that's right that's
you know in denmark if if you are a
human being in denmark you cannot live a
year without at least once eat this cake
it's a and if you're a school child
you'll eat it at least
five at least five times a year and it's
called the in directly translated the
dream cake
and it's it's it's just a danish
invention and uh i thought
if i should bring anything danish i had
to um
to bake and to bake this cake for for
you guys and how kind of that tom he
baked us a cake yeah
what and what in your oven
in my oven and how do you say it in
danish because i do love the sound of
the danish language yeah the dream cake
is turmeric
and it was a lady up in northern another
northern part of jutland in denmark who
made it
um
it's a place called vincel
and then there was a cake competition
several years later in 1960
and it apparently won
um there and then it was called the
dream cake by the by the company that
wanted to produce it so it could so so
so it could be sold
and then it just spread out all over
denmark but only denmark to my knowledge
well
as just before we bring it in
i don't know if you listen to the
friendship onion well actually i do i
know you do listen
but as you know
johnny clues can sometimes get things
slightly wrong
but here listen to this poetry he's
written here
if your dreams had a flavor then it
would probably taste like a decadent
danish dream cake
what a lovely thing you say john
one you can be so romantic
it's so nice
[Laughter]
hours now before we eat this can i go
for a quick pee
no
tom i'm back and what a fantastic p it
was
oh good for you dom what do you know
about the danish dream cake well let's
see i'm currently desperately scrolling
down
through our show this is a new cake to
me is it a new cake to you too bills dom
i've never had it and and casper cooked
it as he said in my oven
oh jeez oh god it's all gone wrong and
yeah
oh tom it's all over his jeans oh god
oh
god it's good i know it's a good job
you're not here tom well that's because
you guys are clear
while you guys are cleaning up i'll read
a little bit of a burp here because this
looks really delightful
i'm gonna taste it while you read yeah
okay do it the simple sponge cake coated
with a coconut caramel topping goes by
the danish name
yeah which translates to dream cake
while the cake itself seems fairly
simple it requires the perfect balance
of technique and patience to get it
right wow oh god you're not supposed to
eat it with a fork now go on dom baker's
combined flour sugar butter egg milk and
vanilla to create a soft and moist
sponge cake
may seem simple
yet is the perfect base for showcasing
the sweet coconut topping oh makes
you perfectly balanced the coconut sugar
mix that gives this cake its
characteristic taste in caramelized
topping the thick animal topping is sure
to linger on your textbooks similar to
the lasting memories of a beautiful
dream hence the name of the cake really
initial thoughts thoughts
tom it is
absolutely delicious
dearest johnny have you got a piece out
there get a piece and john i will give
you a hundred dollars if you make me a
cup of coffee with that that coffee
would be so good with us do you need a
coffee no
200
john
i'll never give him the money i'll never
get no no no no no no no no no we don't
do that yeah yeah don't get money yeah i
look i keep bringing the [ __ ]
i should have told you that that the
dream cake should not be eaten with a
fork what do you eat with with your
hands dome
honestly now i'll show you the technique
like this
i've seen not checking it before okay
casper you said that um school kids in
denmark
would
eat it at least five times a year what
are those five specific times in the
year where they would be um
required to eat dream cake well every
time if you can basically say
every time
in the school
there's an arrangement where where
people say bring a cake
then then it will all may almost always
be this cake or a chocolate cake
so it will be basically at school
you know any time at school don't any
time of year
all the time
i didn't i've not i didn't sneak a piece
of this before today
because i wanted to taste it live
truthfully on the show yeah and tom i'm
not a huge cake person i'm not
you know it's not my it wouldn't be my
go-to i'm a savory person but
i'm not going too far when i say dom
this is the best cake i have ever eaten
okay
what do you feel about that really this
is
something
my god i've got a fairy fart
i have no i have no length but you need
to know
to teach you the technique i don't like
my fingers getting dark okay okay
yeah pick it up with your hands i've got
two forks very small forks now john
with no arms to them
all my sushi with my hands i like
cuisines in which they ask you to eat
with your hands like you eat
food and then there's something about
eating with your hands that makes us a
little more intimate you know you should
enjoy it but you've got really dirty
fingers i would never eat from your
hands i'll tell you that
no no don't eat from my hands you'll get
an infection oh my god that is an
amazing cake good good feeling
has john got a piece yet from from start
to finish you were cooking it at billy's
house from start to finish
how many how many um hours it took
how long it took to cook it
about an hour
from the start to finish
i i i get the recipe bills get the
recipe dom is
the topping is incredible with that
coconut and it's just the brown sugar
coconut
flakes
and the butter
and the little milk that's it a dream
cake tastes best at room temperature it
freezes well so you can enjoy a slice
for many months or if you simply can't
resist its divine flavor which i for one
cannot
then you can store it in the
refrigerator for up to and including 10
days
fantastic
i tell you what you've changed my life
casper okay i don't i mean you wrote
some good songs
but you haven't done anything that's
impressed me like this cake okay you
should be a baker you
you should burn your guitar and use it
as a fire for bacon dream cakes i will
but maybe it's your oven that's perfect
i don't know what it is but that is one
of the best things i've ever tasted cool
i wouldn't i'll make you 10 of them i
would not have expected before i go home
you look very nervous at the oven you
didn't look like a guy that was going to
produce something wonderful
but it's difficult in your kitchen
because it was hard to find things well
you just need to ask god i've given you
yeah but you went away yeah i had to go
i had to go to the gym and pump up my
legs i don't know if i've told you but
i'm trying to get a bigger butt
let's give it some scores i'm not gonna
score it because obviously i'm not
eating it but i look forward to scoring
it next weekend and making really feel
jealous that i'm eating a slice of your
cake okay let's do scores
dom
yeah
i can't i can't give a ten i can't
because nothing in the world nothing in
the world is perfect
so i can't but i've got to give it
a 9.98
wow
honestly dom this will blow you i'm
amazing dude there's dearest johnny hold
on
did you taste any did you oh hold on
johnny in here that's the best cake dom
i've ever had in my life
it's the best cake that john's ever had
in his life as well
who knew denmark was hiding such a a
culinary cake treasure
and it's a good band name as well dream
cake dream cake that is a good name
dom it is absolutely delightful let me
tell you what it's like with a coffee so
i've i've given it a double point system
which we've never done before but i've
given it a 9.98
now casper give it a score for taste
should i give it a score for taste
so i should give myself a score well not
really because you're doing the cake and
not your specific cake making skills
okay
so i should give it one i would straight
10
a 10 a 10. it's a 10 drum
uh now how does it look is it gonna
bring is it gonna bring down the look or
are you delighted with the look as well
don't
i think it will bring you joy
it's a it's a very beautiful
simple sponge
um but slightly slightly darker on the
bottom and then the top has
i would say
a half inch
to almost three quarters of an inch of a
topping that can only be described as
exquisite tongue
so i'd have to say aesthetically
and and it's spongy you've done a
wonderful job here casper thank you i i
wasn't expecting this good i was
our aesthetics oh
dom it's another
9.98
it's a beautiful looking thing
give it a give it a score for us well i
i i think i i think actually i i think
it it
you know it looks really really good
as it should as a dream cake but i don't
think i i think i have another
aesthetic uh thing than you have you
know oh really should you i don't think
it's it's particularly beautiful cake
well you you're you're wrong casper but
carry
i would actually give it something like
three a three how can you give that a
three you mad ma'am because i do you
look at a sunset and give it a three i
find it kind of ugly do you look at a
beautiful white horse galloping across
the field and say that's a three
but
do you look at me ready to dive into the
pacific ocean with my speedos on and
give out
three yeah
but that's i i think maybe a two and a
half would be more realistic i think i
think it's a kind of ugly and an ugly
cake that tastes fantastic okay okay
sorry for that no no worries dom dom
you're gonna i know there's high scores
coming you if i was you i'd i'd get on a
motorbike and get here
but anyway
yes i look forward to it you'll love it
don
usefulness
what would you do with such a cake
could you make something else with it
it's a cake
you can throw it at people
but would they would they unless they
caught it in their mouths
yeah well hold on till i have a sip of
my hundred dollar coffee i mean your
wife your beautiful wonderful wife said
it was very very useful to her yesterday
but just because she ate it yeah well
she said this is really useful but i
want to know if i've got this in my
fridge and like just a couple other
things i've got a banana
i've got some chili oil i've got three
eggs
and i've got a
packet of milkshake is there anything i
can do maybe try it in the milkshake
maybe
who knows maybe maybe i'm i'm going it
out it's good
it's a cake
end cake milkshake you could probably
what about ice cream
dream cake ice cream oh that could be a
review up into the vanilla ice cream
little bits of it
you have dream key dream cake vanilla
ice cream you
you tried to figure that out yeah i
think that's a good thing because i
i think you would be you're good at i i
have the impression that you're pretty
good at mixing things new things
together in a original way so you you
will do the dream cake ice cream i do
like complicated flavors billy will tell
you that i can't wait to try this cake
so usefulness can you take it can you
put it in your pocket bills in a
separate bag for a couple of hours go on
a journey and then take out your pocket
and it still resembles the dream cake or
would it degrade over a certain amount
of travel
no it could easily do that i think you'd
be looking at degradation
i think um
i
if you took it to a dinner party and
said oh i just threw this up in an hour
in the kitchen people would be impressed
with you dumb so if you want to impress
people it's very very good but if you
want to use it for something else which
is what i always think of usefulness
then i'm sorry i can only give it a
6.5
that's high score that's high school
will be juicy for usefulness casper i
would say i would
keep in the low low 4
4 ish four-ish not bad yeah but
the the useful thing about it is that
it's very easy to make
is it yeah so that's very useful well
you'll you look quite stressed that's
why i had to leave the house i thought
i was worried that things were going to
be thrown
okay yeah but this is
an easy cake to make well it's
absolutely delicious thank you super
casper what a wonderful thing to bring
for us and i'm so sorry that my friend
and associate and a long time um
compatriot is not here to enjoy but he
will get it next week if i remember to
take out the freezer yeah but maybe we
have
raised the expectations too high
well it's hard to imagine but spring is
here it's time for us to feel the lovely
soft grass beneath our toes but first
off you need to get your lawn looking
and feeling good and i'll tell you
who'll help with that sunday a fantastic
company
i'll tell you how they do it you go to
their website
put in your address
and they know exactly because of your
soil type and all that stuff what
fertilizer all that stuff what to send
you i did it about a month ago
and my lawn looks absolutely amazing
best it's ever looked it's fantastic and
another great thing they don't use all
the chemicals all the pesticides
in traditional lawn care
there is 90 million pounds of pesticides
every year sunday is changing all of
that we don't need it sunday will help
you grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty chemicals
and sunday is offering our listeners
20
off
full season plans start at just a
hundred and twenty nine dollars and you
can get twenty percent off at checkout
when you visit
get sunday dot com slash onion
that's twenty percent off
your custom plan
at getsunday.com
do you love coffee
i love coffee i can't think of a morning
without it well i tell you a great
company that you need to check out
trade
trade look for all the best coffees
in the country all over the world and
they deliver it directly to your door
i've been using it for a few months now
and i haven't had a coffee i didn't like
yet
it really is amazing they've got expert
tasters who taste thousands of coffees
narrow it down to 450
and then you go on their website take a
quiz on what kind of flavors you like
what you like to get
and they will deliver coffee that is
fantastic
and if you don't like the coffee
they will
set you up with one of their experts and
they will exchange it for one that they
know that you will like it's great
they'll deliver it in whole bean or
already ground whatever way you like it
and i tell you it'll be some of the best
coffee you've ever had i had a colombian
coffee this this week and it was really
one of the best ones i've ever had in
the house and right now trade is
offering new subscribers a total of
thirty dollars off your first order plus
free shipping when you go to
drinktrade.com
onion that's more than 40 cups of coffee
for free get started by taking their
quiz at drinktrade.com
onion and let trade find you a coffee
that you'll love that's drinktrade.com
onion
for 30 off
as musicians and as singers
you guys ever feel that
something like a cake or a cup of coffee
can compromise performance is there
something that you will or won't eat for
a performance because couldn't cake kind
of make you a little drowsy a little
dopey that's a good point dom
i don't know if you have that before you
perform but i know that um
like i know for a fact if you because i
know some people who worked with him ken
lauch the wonderful
um
filmmaker he when he works with actors
he doesn't like them to have a large
lunch
he he
he'll walk around the the tables and say
i think that's enough we've got an
afternoon to do because it does doesn't
it if you have a big meal that
a lot of your energy goes to
um
kind of digesting that meal so as far as
that yeah i don't like to
i don't like to eat a lot before a
performance and if i'm singing
i i try to avoid dairy
i feel like even though i i love a nice
latte or something i'd have my coffee
black and just with a little sugar
before a performance which is exactly
the way that johnny clues has given me
this hundred dollar coffee which is
absolutely delicious john thank you very
much i was very kind i didn't think
you'd have done that i think i thought
you'd have just said no no no one bother
no
sorry about you no no
i'm i'm i'm usually not singing
on stage so i'm just playing the guitar
but it's the same not nothing heavy
um
and usually i'm so busy just before the
concerts that
very often i don't even get anything to
eat so
and then i eat something after the
concert and have a few beers
that's the most important thing a few
beers after the concert
effort
here for whitestone
yeah german german wheat beer that's
right
yeah lovely stuff well thank you very
much for bringing that that was great
cool now so
so if people wanted to hear the music of
the tokyo ensemble which i'm absolutely
sure they will
um where would they find it they would
find it in
spotify and all these
youtube and all these things all these
places where it's all over the place and
then and then maybe you can say today
you know young people today they hear
they listen to maybe
30 seconds of something to make up their
mind if they like it or not but remember
it's it's a music history so they'll be
both you can the first thing you hear
can be a folk song or it could be a
classical song or it could be a more
in between things so so give it a chance
and and listen for
to
take a few of them and listen for more
than 30 seconds and
yeah it's very difficult the different
things and it's fun with with
christopher leasing
tribute song for instance and we have a
wonderful gollum as well
yeah danish
priscilla tolkien just loved our golem
right so he's used just like very very
he's called paul diesing right
and we have yeah a lot of wonderful
uh sopranos and baritone singers and so
on so it takes it's it's it's it's not
an easy listen
it's not but it's a it's a it's a big
body of work like it's over four cds did
you say yeah it's a it's over four hours
of music
and it and it goes the arrangements goes
from one one single voice and and up to
full full symphony orchestra with choir
and organ
and soloists so so it's this that span
because that there's also one of the
things that i've really wanted to make
it you know very different in the
arrangements all the time
so in some way in the same way that
peter jackson
invent not invented but showed the world
all these different parts of middle
earth lot lorien
and menace terrace and rohan where dom
was and
they were all so
different within this middleweight is
that your inspiration for
like as you say there's a full symphony
orchestra so you feel like somewhere in
that world that music is correct
obviously and sometimes tolkien gives
the direct hint like um galateri is said
to have a harp so of course we use a
harp on that song if there's any clues
directly
so and and the eagles song
is described as with trumpets and
everything and so so we had to have an
orchestra there and so on right
um but it but yes it's it's about it's
about making it
you know
so sorry that you actually could believe
in this this could be
like we have a music history i mean you
say from brahms
from brahms to prince yes that is is
that funky is it funky and um we have a
music history that goes even further
back than brahms right we have we go
back to bach and dowel and renaissance
music right uh-huh um so maybe and who
knows maybe maybe bach
is um
funky
because you you just start with brahms
right don yeah brahms yeah brahms to
prince but but but but
back in the day
when when brahms started there were
elements of things that he did that were
quite funky for people walking around in
his time they were like wow brahms is
the guy you know yeah i mean maybe maybe
maybe
you know bach for instance is and and
and this barack music and and and also
renaissance music it's dance music right
so it was written this this sounds like
the perfect time to do a funky for you
[Music]
dom
yeah invented the scale
for is it funky which went from brahms
to of course prince is most purple
yeah
is it funky for you so you're saying
that you're going to go before brahms so
so maybe maybe we could try some bach
and see if it's funky i i think now i
could place them back you you'll have to
could you could you have patience with
me because um
i'm not a classical guitarist anymore
i'm a tolkien guitarist but i'll do some
back for you then
remember you wear a classical guitarist
so go back to that yeah i i can i can
play a little bit bach for you hold on
should i do that i believe this will be
the this will be the first ever
live
funky for you everything else has been
pre-recorded track so this is the first
time we're getting a live funky for you
performance and and that in itself is
funky
all of a sudden it's funky and whatever
you choose casper could you could you
make it a slightly lengthy piece because
i'd like to enjoy my dream cake and a
hundred dollar coffee please i'll do a
piece of pac as good as i can but if i
play a couple of mistakes
does that make it
funky or less funky mistakes i'd i like
i like live well we'll have today
fair enough okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
absolutely beautiful
okay hearing live music immediately
pumps up the funk level because
live music is always the best way to get
it that was fantastic watching someone
play the guitar at such a high level
like that is so impressive thank you
very much don is that great it's it's
the basis of my musicality really
it's the classical guitar but of course
it's 20 years since i've it since since
i really
you know you have to you have to
practice six hours a day in order to
keep the level that i had once you know
um yeah
as it's amazing what the human body as
we've said a few times done when people
you know
specialize in anything and spend a lot
of time doing something whether it's a
sport
musician that you can actually make your
body do that like i could practice that
for two years and wouldn't be able to
play that but you just kind of you know
it's just uh it's incredibly watched
thank you for that casper thanks thanks
it's my pleasure but was it funky tom
was it funky like i said pop just just
hearing it live immediately makes it
more funky than it would have been if i
was hearing that on there on a cd so i'm
gonna say
in terms of the level of funk
from
brahms to to prince that is most purple
i'm going to say
a simon and garfunkel level of
monkey it's pretty funky we were
listening to paul simon yesterday as you
were cooking your cake gracefully baking
gracefully iceland brilliant thanks a
lot yeah i got one
i will give it
a smith's
level of funk because i really always
enjoyed johnny mars guitar playing
and it was fantastic live
he put something when i saw the smiths
live
i couldn't take my eyes off what johnny
marr was doing so i'm going to give it a
smith's level of funk and it was
definitely funky and and you're saying
sorry we i think we stopped you as you
were talking about this so that was bach
johan sebastian what is the piece called
alemante
and from his um
sweden
e minor yeah
and that would have been dance music
an element is by definition dance
music but because because it's yeah it's
a dance this this is probably
not been like that at that time late by
rock like it's it's it's more early
baroque and renaissance that's that's
100 dance music
so
educate us in
that time who would have played that
bach was one of his best friends was the
worst at as far as we know the world's
one of the world's best luteinists
called silvio's leopold vice
and he would have been able to play
these things but it's amazing that you
went specific and told me actually who
would i just meant what type of person
like would that be
a loot player anywhere
people would learn that
in a royal violin
yeah and at royal courts and but not in
a bar
someday would they no no that would be
folk music right right okay that would
definitely be folk music you wouldn't be
able to hear luke in a bar and would
people sit and watch it or would they be
up
dancing
at least in the early baroque and
renaissance they would be dancing
and
maybe maybe bach is a little bit
different
different than
at and the time after him
maybe that was where
it started to that people actually take
take music very seriously it was
absolutely beautiful thank you casper
charming
dumb
what a lovely chat we've had
darling hasn't it been wonderful i wish
you were here dom you would love this
yeah i wish i could bring yosemite a
little closer but unfortunately
uh i can't but i did get a chance to
spend some time with you and casper when
i was in la which is lovely and the next
time casper's in town maybe we can all
play some music together absolutely
and thank you very much for coming on
casper um as casper said
we have
played some music together over the
years and i've absolutely loved it and
we've had some great adventures
and
one of the things we did
was we wrote a song together
um which
sort of had sort of birth i suppose when
i was down in new zealand
uh writing
the last goodbye but before i started
the last goodbye i'd written a few ideas
that i felt were kind of tolkienesque
before i saw the movie of the hobbit and
one of the songs was this and it went on
the back burner
and
i played it one night i suppose with you
and we started working together and we
we totally reworked it and it became a
new song
which um we we could finish with uh
today if that's good for you tom
i would love that that would be
fantastic and i'm sure
are always waiting to hear new music for
me bill so yeah let's do it get cozy
thank you and then this song um
and the chorus has
the word namariye
which you know dom
uh is elvish for it's a sort of goodbye
but it's be well
it's a nice way to say goodbye to
someone be well namariye
and uh we thought that fits the song so
uh the song is now called
where it began where it began
[Music]
before
the time
nightmare is longest
you know you can't go on
days go by
and still i stand
the shadow in my eye
shows me
[Music]
the road goes
[Music]
i still see you
and
lies we share
this story is too cruel
to tear me away from me
days go by
and still i stand
the shadow in my
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
let
others fall
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i see
where it begins
[Music]
who can
[Music]
thank you dom
i love it love the way you finished uh
this week thank you caspar it's always
always a pleasure to spend some time
with you it really is
you're such an inspiring it's been
fantastic i'm happy to be here in
wonderful l.a
on the friendship onion
and uh
john will be back eating cake next week
let's not forget yeah um we've raised
expectations oh yeah too much maybe too
much i don't know i don't know
but if you have a anything you'd like to
see or hear on the friendship onion
please send us an email
to um
the friendship onion at castmedia.com or
you can get us on speakpipe.com forward
slash the friendship onion and please
listen to the wonderful music of casper
life and the tolkien ensemble it really
is something very very special it's been
lovely to speak to you today casper
thank you thank you for your story
dominic
enjoy the rest of your tip thanks
it's been a it's been a really cool
thing to have live music for the first
time in the studio and probably
something that we can continue to
explore bill because yeah i know we're
both big fans of music
and to have those little moments of
musical interludes is great but to have
live musicians in the studio brilliant
so thanks for that casper that was that
was really great and and my appreciation
for that song stunning casper's got some
great ideas for things that we can do
together the next time he comes back as
well some lovely lovely hobbit stuff
it'll be great
thank you very much
see you next week on the friendship
onion see you next
[Music]
all through week night you're shining
bright i'm your boy's the baby you're my
[Music]